should a flood hit japan is ready and  their solution is the largest  underground water facility in the world  [Music]  about an hour outside of tokyo is the  metropolitan area outer underground  discharge channel  this tunnel sits 160 feet underground  and is around four miles in length  inside is a network of large vertical  shafts that store flood waters  the giant tunnels were built because  this area of japan was constantly  flooding  now instead of inundating nearby towns  the water flows underground and is  diverted to a river that can handle the  influx of water making sure more than  nine million residents stay dry  [Music]  [Music]  you